- Alright, we are on our
way to Cider House 101.
Our good friend, Mark, is going to
have us along for this ride.
He's gonna show us a fresh-pressed juice,
and a fermented juice.
- [Voiceover] What up, Mark?
- [Voiceover] I wore my
autumn shirt in preparation.
- I wore my fall hair.
- Oh, wait. That's right.
Never touch a black woman's hair.
That's how I lost this finger.
(laughter)
(whimsical music)
- [Voiceover] I am the
founder of 101 Cider House.
At heart, really what I am is a cider guy,
trying to convert people,
thinking that it's just this ridiculous,
sweet, alcho, pop-like substance
that sorority girls are drinking
on a Friday night somewhere,
waking up with a raging hangover.
- Exactly. That's what I thought.
- So, cider isn't just beer for weanies?
- No, and actually
cider is more like wine.
It's apple wine.
- Can you do it with bananas?
- [Man in red shirt] No.
- Let's go inside, alright?
It's just too much talking.
- Hey, wait. Let's go in-cider.
- [Voiceover] In here is
our fresh-pressed juice.
There's yeast contained in the juice
that comes off the orchards.
We don't sterilize it,
we don't pasteurize it.
We put it right into the tank,
and we let it do its own thing naturally.
- This not boozy.
- No.
- [Female] Oh.
- [Male in cap] Ah!
- [Man in white shirt] That's so good!
- [Female] So good.
- [Male in cap] Why don't
I drink more apple juice?
- [Voiceover] When you
get it from the grocery
store, it tastes fake
but this is pure apples.
- And, when it's cloudy, when it's cloudy,
you know, that's when it's good.
- [Female] Whoa!
- [Voiceover] That's
what's going on right here.
- [Voiceover] This is
cider, that's a cider snake.
All that goes in that barrel is juice.
It's really cool, if you
watch inside the tank
a week from now, it's got its own current.
- Well, I think we're
about to drink some cider.
- (singing) I want me some cider,
I want me some cider.
- When it's all finished product,
we bring it into the tasting room.
Cider is actually a culinary-driven
type of experience.
You want to pair it well with food.
- That is some...
(bottle cap popping)
- [Female] Whoo!
- This is our India pale cider.
So, this is a hops cider.
- [Voiceover] Did a lot of dry-hopping
in middle school.
(laughter)
- [Female} I can't.
- Cheers.
(glasses clinking)
- It's kosher. It's vegan-friendly.
This is 100% gluten-free.
It is 100% raw, probiotic, unfiltered,
unpasteurized, and it's
naturally sparkling.
An unripened goat cheese goes
very well with this hop cider.
- So, should I do like sip, bite?
- Swish the cider around in your mouth,
and mix it with the cheese.
- [Voiceover] Oh, yeah.
- l love this cheese.
- [Man in cap] Mmhm.
- I don't know much about pairing,
I show up to work with,
like, blue pants and blue
shirt and Freddy is
like, what are you doing?
(laughter)
- [Voiceover] This is going to be our
Cactus Red cocktail.
Campari, classic liqueur from Italy.
I just take one bottle.
- [Female] Steve, you drunk?
- I'm getting drunk, watching this.
- [Voiceover] Now, we take this Campari,
I'm just gonna stir it up a little bit.
You're taking an old-school
beverage like cider
then you're giving it a whole new spin
and making it craft cider.
(glasses clinking)
- (in unison) Cheers.
- Cheers.
- [Voiceover] Oh, okay.
I can drink a thousand.
- [Female] Oh, yeah.
- It's dangerous.
- I wanna be drinking this at a pool
in Palm Springs when it's a hundred
and fourteen degrees.
- Absolutely.
- Yeah, this is more refreshing
than a glass of water.
- We're gonna go to the official
tasting room over there.
- [Voiceover] The VIP.
- [Voiceover] Grab a
bite of that manchego.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, it smells funky.
- [Voiceover] Cheers.
(glasses clinking)
- Well, it tastes like kombucha.
It does not taste like it smells.
It definitely smells like a wet dog,
but it tastes delicious.
- [Voiceover] The more
I'm drinking on this...
- It grows on you, man.
- [Voiceover] It's getting on me.
I feel sophisticated.
- [Voiceover] Triple funky white wine.
- [Voiceover] Alright.
Last one, Black Dog.
You gotta head out to the bar.
- [Voiceover] Black dog.
- [Voiceover] Are you gonna open this one?
- [Voiceover] Yeah, I'll open it.
- [Voiceover] Can I open it?
- [Voiceover] Now, drop your hand down
and it hold it like a trigger.
And, then watch that mist.
- (in unison) Ooh.
- Now, watch your hand.
There you go.
- Oh, yeah.
Do I look cool like this?
- You look super cool.
- [Voiceover] Now that
we've already popped it,
let's rock it.
Black Dog, it's like a
creamy, black lemonade.
- [Voiceover] Whoa.
- [Female] Intense.
- That's special.
It tastes fresh.
- The thing is, you
make fresh-pressed juice
and you ferment it and
it just gets better.
- Who get turnt at the juice bar?
- I tell you what.
You can drink this with
food, without food.
Cold or hot.
You can have different fruit flavors,
you can add hops.
You can do anything you want to it.
It's the most diverse
beverage on the planet.
- [Voiceover] Usually in this situation,
I'd give you a handshake
to wrap up the video,
but I'm a little tossed
so I think it's hug time.
(laughter)
- [Voiceover] I'm getting out of here.
No! Help me, Freddy.
- [Voiceover] Come on in, Freddy.
(laughter)
- Yeah. There we go.
- That's hilarious.
- I hate hugs.
(laughter)
- Hi.
- Oh, hey guys.
- (in unison) Sarah.
- Up here.
- We made a series.
- It's coming on November 18th.
- Please watch it.
- Get it here.
- Over here.
- (in unison) There, there,
there, over there.
- You got it. I think they got it.
- Okay, I'm out.
- Yeah, they got it. Bye.
- If you look in the
area then you can see it.
It'll be released 2015, November.
(indistinct yelling)
- Okay.